[Musik]
servus liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu lässig kochen mit
tschuwaschow unser heutiges thema ist
verfeinern
es gibt in der küche nichts was man
nicht noch verfeinern könnte in den
original bayrischen wurstsalat kann man
zb verfeinern indem man einfach noch
zwei klinik lag sie hinten mit zahlen
dazu gibt und was wäre eine
weihnachtsgans wenn sie nicht vorher
fängt gebraten wird einen gebratenen
weihnachtsgans
die free sie nicht das ist nichts für
mich da aber nur kurz mal hier und heute
fangen wir ein dessert
ich habe hier einen ganzen und holly
gekocht die williams christ birne im
williams christ berlin schnaps die
schmeckt an und für sich schon prima ich
würde aber noch feiner wenn man einen
schuss zwischenwasser zugibt dass analog
keine etiketten drauf
naja uns wird schon sehr charmant wie
sie ist und nicht wie schnaps schauen
unterschied schmeckt ist kann der
zwischen wassers könnte aber auch die
chance auf die a40
die sache nur wer ganz matt nix passiert
und wie das feuerschiff mein geschmack
ist mit einer welt die ganze scheiße
blamiert kohl ich mag er ist der einzige
auf zu senken straße hinfahren und
support sind im vorbeifahren wollen aber
schließt geht ja auch nicht gebraten ist
so viel zu sagen früher hatte ich sehr
ab
die höhe geschraubt
[Musik]